bienvenue à la TV 78 je vais vous faire
visiter mon atelier c'est par là une
invitation allez merveillement Patrick
pogut peintre autodidacte de 77 ans est
originaire de Magny-les-Hameaux dès le
début de sa retraite il y a une
quinzaine d'années il se passionne pour
cet art avec une appétence particulière
pour l'aquarelle dessin choix des
couleurs ou des harmonies cette
technique de peinture à l'eau sur papier
nécessite un grand travail préparatoire
ce qui m'intéresse le plus dans
l'aquarelle c'est l'inattendu c'est à
dire que on part dans l'aquarelle dans
le mouillé c'est à dire je mouille
totalement ma feuille et je pose des
pigments on arrive à avoir des effets
tout à fait inattendus qui sont les plus
beaux effets du tableau qu'on a prévu de
faire portrait architecture ou paysage
Patrick pogut fait découvrir au curieux
son travail dans l'atelier de sa maison
une mise en lumière durant les deux
premiers weekends d'octobre pour
l'événement Parcours d'Artistes organisé
par l'association hélium moi j'ai
toujours un peu de mal à savoir si ce
qui me plaît
va plaire au public donc là je vois la
réaction du public je discute avec eux
et c'est des moments qui sont qui sont
super environ 80 participants
originaires de la vallée de Chevreuse
collabore à ce 19ème Parcours d'Artistes
plasticien sculpteur ou photographe ce
voyage artistique se poursuivra le
weekend prochain